*CHRISTMAS BONER INTENSIFIES*
♪ I'm full of Christmas semen; ♪
♪ I don't know what it is but its hot. ♪
♪ It's like Heaven's orgasm ♪
♪ inside an oatmeal cookie shot. ♪
♪ And when I put my Santa hat on, it's a needle full of Christmas glee. ♪
♪ Coating my house in frilly shit, and Disney trademarking intellectual property. ♪
*fake screaming*
♪ 'Cause it's snowing, I love shopping, and I fu-fu-fu-fu-fu-fucking love Christmas! ♪
♪ Setting up the lights so my fucking house sings ♪
♪ 'cause I'm fucking bat-shit crazy about Christmas! ♪
♪ If Christmas was living, I'd fuck it to death, ♪
♪ and then consume its body for its Christmas breath. ♪
♪ 'Cause it's growing, I'm not stopping, and I fu-fu-fu-fu-fu- fucking love Christmas! ♪
Ladies and gentlemen, Jesus Christ on the electric guitar!
*Jesus Christ plays electric guitar*
You applaud! You applaud, goddammit! He died for your sins!
♪ I'll buy all things red and green, ♪
♪ accumulating thousands in debt. ♪
*You cannot beat us.*
♪ I'll let it ruin my life, ♪
♪ making it the best Christmas yet. ♪
♪ And I'll play those Christmas carols until my ears will bleed with Christmas cheer. ♪
*whispers Christmas cheer*
♪ It'll scare the shit out of you, but its only getting bigger every year! ♪
*fake screaming again*
♪ 'Cause it's snowing, I love shopping, and I fu-fu-fu-fu-fu fucking love Christmas! ♪
♪ I love those stop motion specials that scare the shit out of me, ♪
♪ 'cause I'm fucking bat-shit crazy about Christmas! ♪
♪ I bathe in hot chocolate 'til my skin is red, ♪
♪ and I quote Christmas Story 'til your soul is dead! ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm soaking in sweet toppings, and I fu-fu-fu-fu-fu-fucking love Christmas!!! !♪
♪ And the deals. ♪
♪ And the meals. ♪
♪ And the feels. ♪
♪ And the steals at the Sears. ♪
♪ Keep it longer. ♪
♪ Make it stronger. ♪
♪ Nothings wrong here. ♪
♪ I could stay here all year. ♪
HELP HE'S A FUCKING MAD MAN!!!!!
♪ I'm crazy. Getting lazy. ♪
♪ Something's tasty. At the Macy's downtown. ♪
♪ Getting higher! ♪
♪ Feeling wired! ♪
♪ I'm inspired! ♪
♪ I'm on fire right now! ♪
♪ I love the over-marketing for making doubloons! ♪
♪ By the way this songs available on iTunes! ♪
*shameless*
♪ I WANNA SMASH IT OPEN 'TIL IT'S STIFF AND COLD! ♪  ﻿
♪ AND THEN SEARCH ITS BRAINS FOR ITS CHRISTMAS GOLD! ♪
♪ AND THEN DRINK ITS BLOOD 'TIL I LOSE CONTROL!﻿♪
♪ AND THE CHRISTMAS MADNESS WILL TAKE ITS TOLL!♪
*pew*
Hm.
Don't ever fucking do that again!
I'm sorry!
What he has is a sickness
that can only be cured by repression...and tranquilizers.
Yeah, that was fucking scary!
♪ *slow* It's snowing, I love shopping, and I fu-fu-fu-fu-fu-fucking love Christmas. ♪
♪ Enough to build tranquilizer immunity. ♪
♪ I must be fucking bat-shit crazy about...♪
Wait a minute. What did he say?
*loud* ♪ I'll kill anyone not celebrating with me! ♪
♪ Your resistance is feeding my insanity! ﻿♪
♪ 'Cause it's snowing, I love shopping, ♪
♪ So put the star on top the tree and buy me a fucking T.V.! ♪
♪ We're going on a shopping spree! ♪
♪ My stocking's filled with DVDs! ♪
♪  My heart is filling up with glee! Can't help what's coming over me! I FU-FU-FU-FU-FU-FUCKING LOVE CHRISTMAS!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
*sigh*
Boy,
That did feel good.
Thanks so much you guys! :)
Hey Jesus.
*plays 2 notes*
Subscribe to Channel Awesome for more of the Nostalgia Critic!